c'est un bébé jaguar je vais t'appeler
je serai là pour
défendre je me disais je pvais ne pas
aller en cour tu vas à l'école c'est
tout je vais demander à un élève d'aller
chercher les grenouilles au labo je va
qu'estce que tu fais je suis en train
d'appeler
la c'est quoi ça ça
c'est
cher doc la situation s'aggrave de jour
en jour il ne reste qu'un seul et unique
Jaguar dans la
région on doit aller la sauver fait ans
qu'on qu jle on
n vous êes ven tous les de malgré tout
c'est ma de biologie suit depuis New
York il faut vraim qu'on ton père
bien complètement
[Musique]
secoué sa meilleure amie est au
Jaguar je la ramèner dans un corridor
biologique où elle sera en sécurité
c'est un animal sauvage des trafiants
[Musique]
il on va trouver le corridor tuas plus
rien à craindre je
on est ensemble tu te
souviens